i feel it'll be useful
to continue
making these reports
slash updates around
the unique
style of satori
that i've been experiencing
and there will likely be
useful insights for people
and it makes it so that the
unique expression of infinity
that has pierced this veilus veil this
gateless gate
undergoes the process of reflecting on
the transmission of the unique
style of finding
that they went through and that they're
continuing to go through and
by distilling down
their satori and sharing it with people
this will be something likely very
helpful
and mainstream enlightenment
which is why one of the projects that
we're excited about in
la is to
be able to capture and distill
people's unique finding
of themselves as infinity
in short video style testimonials
around what happened
what they did what happened
and what they're doing now
because everybody's going to have a
different style of
what paths what books
aphorisms retreats
which major planetary mystic traditions
were studied
which entheogens were taken
how many times at what doses
what traumas were healed and integrated
found to be treasures
and then what happened during that
piercing of that veilsville that
gateless gate
that gradual that then came to that
sudden
what was that like
what level of intensity was it did your
nervous system go into shock
and there's all these profound stories
around that and then what's going on now
the light bulb was flickering now
staying on what does the abiding
process look like
for i am infinity i am
the infinite creator expressing itself
what does the abiding process look like
and so to capture content like that and
share it with people is going to be a
critical part of
enlightening our civilization
mainstreaming
awakening making satori fun
and i've had people ask me to
be featured on that and so we're still
putting together the
funding and team to be able to
mainstream those operations and so
that's where you can come in and help
join the channel get exclusive benefits
and also support us
in actualizing these endeavors
and i've had people ask me about my own
as well and i referenced them to the
video i made about two months ago on
wadat
al wujud the sufi metaphysic which was
really
understanding that the
sum of all unveiling and finding
was a huge
part of my satori
and made a video about that but i'll
dive into it a little bit deeper here in
this
satori report and i'll keep doing these
likely
and sharing other people's so for those
that
potentially weren't following
when i was completely off the grid in
2020
for 10 straight months from january 2022
october 2020.
and it just so happened to work out that
everything that was going on with the
planet was
happening at the time given our
ignorance of how to be masters of dna
and biology and the code of life which
we could have taken care of
immediately upon zoonosis if we actually
had a operating system on a planetary
level that was
monitoring this and having artificial
general intelligence being able to
calculate
out when it's happening and then
provide the intervention to prevent
such ridiculous catastrophes
we need to think more like star trek and
less like chimpanzees throwing poop at
each other's faces
at the
un general assembly and fortune 500
ceo level
um
in the summer of 2020
i had been studying the
smartest geniuses that have ever lived
so if you put everybody on a power law
distribution
all 100 plus billion people that have
lived and died
and i have these visuals and high level
perception
the first book that i published and
at the very tail
end of the power law distribution there
are only
a couple thousand or tens of thousand or
maybe a hundred thousand or some
people that have lived and died before
us today
that have made the vast majority of the
planetary architectural
awakening advancements
and so i was studying them
who they were what their habits were
what they learned about the nature of
reality
what they architected to maximize human
potential
and i remember my friend that i had
interviewed
i believe three times
at that third interview
his name's bernard gunther had shared
with me
how much he had been enjoying
sri aurobindo and how he was one of
the most clear channels of
the nature of reality and this was
in
the fall of september ish
fall of 2019
and so i began investigating srira bindo
around that time but i really got deep
into him around the summer of 2020
both with the adventure of consciousness
by
sat prem on him and also
the life divine which is in many ways
like
a magnum opus and
the synthesis of yoga and
sri aurobindo introduced me to
so much because he basically distilled
vedanta and the upanishads
and was a synthesis of the east and the
west
and so was the mother mira alfasa who
was his
partner in metaphysics
and so this led to a micro satori for me
around the summer of 2020 which i did
not know was a micro satori at that time
only now looking back at it i actually
have the lexicon to be able to
describe it and the understanding
to recognize it
and so i had this recognition
you know i ran downstairs i had the
big sheet of paper
poster sized and i wrote source
exploring infinity i went outside
and i took a picture of myself holding
it
posted it and i was like this is it
this is metaphysical truth
there's this source
dao brahman god
the infinite
that is exploring
these realities
eternally infinitely
and you can't ever come to the end of
exploration
there's no beginning there's no end
and there's no separation
one infinite creator expressing itself
and when i was coming to that
realization
i was recognizing that
this is going to be the fundamental
metaphysical truth that i build
conceptual frameworks on top of moving
forward
because i had been looking all over
science all over consciousness
all over entheogens all over the
planetary mystic traditions attending
so many of the different retreats
reading so many of the different texts
revisiting them over and over again
because every time i would have
a greater exegesis i would draw out
more salience because i had upgraded
my conceptual
understanding of metaphysical truth and
revisited it
to extract more salience from it
even right now i've already visited
confucius's analects and lao says
doubted qing
and yet i still revisit them
and draw out more and more salience from
them
i still revisit biblical stories
we just posted another video on
a trip report around a micro dose on
magic mushrooms still revisiting
enthiogens
this is what is meant by the workout
this is the gym
this is the re-baselining the abiding
as i am infinity
this is the sitting out in the sun
and just abiding as infinity
and just profundity
sheer indescribable ineffable perfect
profundity
and then boom an intuitive lightning
bolt comes through and it's like
there's your answer for what you were
working on with your project
that you were struggling to try and
figure out and boom
in silence
it comes
and so that was really profound around
summer 2020
and i knew that that was going to be the
fundamental
metaphysics
and i still hadn't broken through to the
shared eternal awareness yet
and it was interesting having
published the
first book high level perception
and then having the plan to
get the hard and soft cover versions out
by
christmas
because what ended up happening was that
the macro satori
as i'm calling it here to try and make
these unique
distinctions in the actual style of
unique finding for this expression of
infinity
that that macro satori came around
december 15
2020 which was literally right around
the time
of the jupiter saturn grand conjunction
which has so many profound significances
that i was on after
looking at this word wadat al-wujud the
aphorism of the sufi metaphysic
the unity of all being in existence and
just revisiting that
month after month for a year
and landing on
eben arabi and then
landing on the william
chidix translation of what
what that aloo jude means
and i land on that page and i'm reading
it
i'm just sitting on the couch reading it
on the laptop
and remember again i hadn't broken
through to the shared eternal awareness
yet
i had been conceptualizing it right
chapter 9 on consciousness and high
level perception really dives deep into
the
recognition that the awareness
is shared that that consciousness is a
collective
consciousness
but really the true knowing
of it in the heart embodied in the
essence as well as the eternity of
it as an eternal awareness
was not fully there and so i'm reading
william chitik's piece
and it says that
[Music]
is not simply translated as being
or existence
but as finding and that ibnarabhi
likely through these
aphorisms was communicating
meaning the sum of all unveiling and
finding
boom pop
broke through whole nervous system went
into shock
i'll explain what that meant for me was
that
i began to recognize
that
infinity or source
we as these expressions of that
are all in our own unique
process of
unveiling and finding
ourselves as the one infinite creator
what the greeks meant by know thyself
the delphic maxim on the top of the
temple of apollo at delphi
and so i recognize that wow that's the
pupil
the shared eternal awareness is the
pupil
and the iris is the unique coloration
of that expression and that was
so profound basically taking the
integral
of all eight billion unique
styles of unveiling and finding wadat
al-wujud and learning it as that
broke me through to where even going
from this alan sakyon character
who i don't even know to
this atlas character
even the atlas character upon that
moment
dissolved
there's just infinitude at that point
now there's an abiding process where
occasionally the infinitude will
seemingly be in the background
rather than being aware of the
infinitude
and so that's the that's the gym
that's the abiding process
in the infinitude that i've been doing
and we'll be doing a little bit more
content around
the astrological significance around
that
december 20th 2020 point
but very very clearly for me
that day and that next couple of days
was so profound
because the eternal shared awareness
made sense
and that's when all of these analogies
came through the
coloration
on the observer the pure
bear empty awareness the witness that is
shared
look shared right
and then that's the pupil and then this
is the iris
this is the unique coloration this
expression of infinity has
words and this expression of infinity
has art
and so the sky and the clouds made sense
and the
the phone screen that
is locked versus when it's modulating
all of the different
applications made sense
the screen in the movie made sense
the ocean and the waves made sense all
these analogies
and that's what prompted me
to communicate the direct path
you know when you know
truly you know when you know nobody
needs to tell you
that you know nobody needs to put a gold
star on your forehead like fred davis
was saying on our show
you know when you know and at that point
you're ready to vortex up
other people and that's when i made the
first direct path video
and since then
we've made
16 direct path videos and a lot of other
content
around how to
undergo this most rapid piercing of the
veilless veil
to the god-realized state
to your nature of infinitude as
peace happiness and awe
ananda truth consciousness bliss
and so
after that macro satori
and the dissemination of these direct
path videos
and this other content
in service to the stewarding of
the awakening of other expressions of
infinity
turning inward to pierce the veilus veil
and recognize themselves as the one
infinite creator
most recently
this abiding process has
really
went to a new level where
there's a
a constancy in being
infinity
that's just the best way to describe it
yeah so
if you think about it it's like this
alan
sakyon character that was intoxicated by
maya
was dissolved
and then there was this atlas character
that was partly gnostic
partly
ayani partly liberated
and even that character
dissolved
because the identity was still there
that the identity was
that character
with a more enlightened state but still
identity
as the character and then
this most recent abiding
what it does is it
brings a constancy of
you our source you
are infinity i
am that
i and my father are one truly
that's when you really know what those
words mean
and to be source slash infinity
full time
that is the full realization state
that's when you are ramana maharshi
jesus christ lautsa confucius
zarathustra
heraclitus and parmenidus made so many
profound realizations
the synthesis of those two is the nature
of reality
the changeless change
we'll get to that here
in a moment
but this process of abiding
in source in
infinity as identity with
that you are
that not the body and not
even the awareness
but i am source i am infinity itself
i am source i am infinity
that is itself the nerguna brahmin
it itself has no
characteristics it has no attributes
there is no agent
it's beyond everything and beyond
nothing
you are that
and then true simultaneity is when you
also recognize
that you are also
the eternal shared awareness that is the
agent of source slash
infinity across all of these creation
designs
and then again true simultaneity
is recognizing that
you are also the unique firework
of that source slash infinity expressing
itself
in this specific creation design
so the outward path
as you infinite slash source
realize it becomes like lao tzu said woo
way effortless action of the absolute
highest morality
and that's where there's no free will
because the free ness of the will
is consumed by only the highest moral
choice each time
so there's no longer a choice it's only
the highest moral because you truly
know your true metaphysical nature
and in that outward firework expression
there is a lot of
like charlie munger identified
grabbing these core
teachings from the major disciplines
science engineering entrepreneurship
art digital quotient
and being able to weave the polymethy
of that with the spiritual mystic
realizations
and then architect the maximal
beauty of that firework maximizing human
potential
and so the abiding process is really a
constancy it's the light bulb that stays
on and then it's also
a way effortless only
absolute highest morality epic
sensitivity true simultaneity across
those layers
and a jedi like joseph and the code of
many colors
ability to navigate communication
with other expressions of infinity
where very surgically and skillfully
gracefully and wisely you act as a
mirror for
them to pierce their veil veilus
veil and that's
so critical
there are lots of people that don't know
how to be
a jedi across all layers simultaneously
one of the things that helps you is
emotional intelligence having a high eq
having high nunchi and in order to have
that
you need to have went through lots of
combinations
of human dialectic in order to know how
to smoothly
navigate that space
for each and every single unique
expression of infinity to be a unique
mirror for them exactly what they need
for their piercing of the veilus fail
because everybody is going to be
different in exactly what they need
that's why the
sat guru the one that truly
knows truth is
the truth of infinitude is just
channeling through
them and uniquely being able to
share a good question or
statement that makes the other
expression of infinity
inquire into their own nature and then
god realized themselves
and so those that host
satsang that
don't have the jedi-like simultaneity
that don't know how to speak about even
the dualism
of there being both ignorance and
knowledge as well as the non-dualism
where those two are merged in one
that don't know how to speak about the
unique
creative expression of infinity that is
each of these irises
that just completely cancels it out as a
dream delusion but that does not
recognize it also as a unique expression
that is not true simultaneity
so it's up to the seeker to be able to
navigate the space
of these saat songs and these gurus
and identify the most saat guru
the one that's really the truest channel
of all of the layers of all of the
nuance of all of the simultaneity
that's able to most jedi like navigate
for each unique expression of infinity
inquiring about its own true nature
and that's where i'm at i'm fielding a
lot of calls right now from people
where they're at one of the very
recognizable stages that i've been at
before
and i'm helping them with questions
with analogies with statements
that help them really click things
together
and they've been communicating to me
frequently that
there are no other people that i can
talk to
about this that get it at the level that
you do
and that's when you know that what's
coming through
is true when it's resonating at that
level with other people
so that's another marker for you to know
that about yourself
when you're ready you know you're ready
you know you've pierced the veil as fail
you know you're ready to communicate it
to other people
and when you know the other
as a unique creative expression of
infinity
all perverse incentives go out the
window
remaining true to the abiding in the
constancy of source and infinity
dissolves all of the perverse incentives
okay so again this was sort of the
little
recap the micro
satori around summer 2020 source
exploring infinity
catalyzed by sri aurobindo the macro
satori the shared eternal awareness
william chidik ibn arabi society
being so influential the unity of all
piercing the veilless veil and finding
yourself as the one infinite creator in
all of the unique styles of that process
right at the end of 2020 around the time
of the jupiter saturn grand conjunction
and then most recently this abiding
this light bulb staying on constantly
i am infinity i am source
i am not the body and i am not
even awareness
awareness is an agent that infinity
that source uses that is shared in
eternal
to experience these dream creation
designs
you are source you are infinity and to
abide
in that to where that becomes home
that becomes the baseline
that your being resonates at like a
tuning fork
and that's vibrationally what attracts
all these people to call in and be like
this is where i'm at i can tell that
you're there
work with me with some questions okay
here's some questions here's a couple
ideas the
serious seekers
are the ones that will take
what you say and immediately apply it
as nisargata maharaj speaks vehemently
about
the two ways are
a tremendous amount of suffering
that infinity catalyzes on itself
as a drill sergeant in order to awaken
out of the egoic contracted energy
towards its true nature and that
process comes with these
methods here where there's this
inner guru the sad guru
where for me it was a lot like this
where it was this
today i use what bentino massaro calls
the
absolute gps callback
but i didn't even have the term satguru
nor absolute gps callback at the time
this was six years ago
but around the time of 2015
there was this indescribable
ineffable seeking toward metaphysical
truth
enough of this maya
what the [ __ ] is our true nature
who are we why are we here
and then the next six years have just
been this relentless
hardcore seeking especially 2020 was
full time
across all of the things that i've been
talking about
entheogens 10-day meditation retreats
reading the spiritual mystical
traditions texts
studying the aphorisms since
the synthesizing science and
neuroscience and consciousness
studies in as well
and then you also have this
seeking where the
complete surrender to a guru happens
i was surrendered to what sri aurobindo
was
channeling through i was surrendered to
what i was learning by rupert spyra
what i was learning by bentino massaro
by nisargata maharaja by ramana maharshi
by laoza by rumi
by the old and new testament
and even great communicators like jordan
peterson
of those incredibly sacred
important spiritual texts
completely surrendered trusting that the
gurus that are communicating
metaphysical truth
are doing it in a way where i don't need
to have this hardcore skepticism and
instead what i need to do
is have a trusted devotion in exactly
what they're saying
and pursue that full time drive my
seeking
impulse full time with hardcore
attentional focus on
what they are telling me
because the truth from infinity source
is flawlessly given the cleanness
of the vessel the purity of the vessel
which you with your seeking radar must
identify who those are
and then what's coming from that
infinite from that source through them
is the gps callback and so for you
to hear it and yet also be like
well i can stay part-time dedicated to
that
so the seekers that come to you
when you have pierced the veilus fail
and realized
recognize that the ones that are most
earnest
as nisargata maharaj bentino masara have
been saying
the more earnestness the more devotion
to truth above everything else
the more full time they are the more
that you send over a piece of content
like you maybe send them i am that by
nisargata
maharaj or maybe you send them betino
masaro's
mirror talks podcast and
maybe you send them to the law of one
material
by raw and if they get back to you in
like a week
and tell you i've
consumed all of the homework that you
gave me
it unlocked this for me
i have more questions that are even more
deep and insightful now
maybe they even produced a piece of
content around what they learned like a
video
of themselves teaching what they had
experienced and learned
that means they themselves are
showcasing how their
micro satori is occurring
which is beautiful they're creating a
paper trail of their own micro satori
as a library for not only themselves but
for the world
it's really important and so those
seekers that are most earnest
those are the ones that are actually
going to
break through those are the ones that
are going to
most efficaciously pierce the veilless
veil
with speed with haste
and yet also with great clarity and also
with
the most
nuanced depths
and variables in the conceptual lattice
work that enables them to abide
in the light bulb constancy
of i am infinity i am source
so this has been where i'm at
now and
that's a little bit on some of the
satori report these are some things that
have been
coming up recently that i just compiled
together as
a couple cute cool things to add at the
end of the satori report
so you are the infinite creator
you are the one infinite creator you are
infinity
you are source you are dao god
brahman you are that i am that tatman
asi
i and my father are one that is your
mantra
that is the metaphysical truth
that is where you must abide what
you must realize piercing that veiless
veil
that gateless gate
and once you recognize that
the outward path like lao tzu said
will weigh effortlessly you weave as the
tantric path your profound realizations
into enlightening our civilization
and this is very much like hide and seek
what happens is in the dreamed creation
designs
that if you don't have conscious
parenting or
if you don't have like what many of the
indigenous parenting is like
where the infant as it evolves
into a child what happens is that the
infant
finds itself as a child to be a
separate finite biologic egoic
entity and so if you don't have
conscious parents if you don't have that
indigenous style understanding to
communicate at that earliest infancy
that you are source you are infinity and
you are a creative expression of that
if you have that you won't have the
contracted egoic energy that forms
which is beautiful but
if you and that's where we're heading
but if you don't have
that conscious parenting indigenous
style parenting where you recognize
as an infant and a child that you are
infinity source expressing itself
then what will happen is it will be like
hide and seek
because the child will become an
adolescent
in an adult and as it undergoes that
process it will seek
peace and happiness in maya in the
dreamed creation design in the illusion
it will become intoxicated
by fame and clout and money
and material possession and greed
and it will believe it can find peace
and happiness
and awe externally and just like in the
parable of the prodigal son
just like we were saying with the
absolute gps callback what happens
is that hiding recognizes that
oh there is something to seek there's
peace and happiness and awe
that is internal as rumi said it's the
diamond
that is already around my neck and then
that
absolute gps callback is so strong
and this is where neo advaita by saying
there's nothing to see
can stop this
hardcore gps callback of the absolute
but it won't fully stop it because the
absolute will just
use a sludge hammer instead as the drill
sergeant of awakening
suffering to wake up that contracted
egoic energy to actually continue the
seeking process
because it still must pierce that veilus
veil to
recognize itself as the eternal shared
awareness
and so then from there that's already a
huge macro level satori step which is
huge because you no longer are consumed
by maya you are no longer the body you
are no longer the contracted egoic
energy
so in the hiding you've now
seeked all the way to the eternal shared
awareness
and now you're seeking all the way to
infinity source itself
you are infinity source itself that is
agentless that is attributeless
that then creates the
agent of the eternal shared awareness
that then
experiences the creation designs
another way to say this is i am dora the
infinite explorer
i am dora the infinite explorer
grab your backpack let's go jump in
vamanos and you didn't
really recognize it until now it's so
cute how even in a cartoon
you can apply what the
main song was in a understanding of
infinity or source
you are the
voyager that
is sent by source by infinity
and that's where the grab your backpack
let's go
and then jump into the dreamed creation
design
dominos and so you're let's go
you know how is the process going to be
for you
in the dream creation design how
much will you get intoxicated by maya if
at all if you have very conscious
parenting and
that style of upbringing will you
take it all the way to your deathbed
where you still haven't turned inward
and that's where the idea of samsara
comes into play
where you undergo the cycle of death and
rebirth
because you haven't underwent nirvana
yet you haven't liberated yourself
from maya
and you're not a bodhisattva
because you take the liberation from
maya
and you weave the profound realizations
in the tantric path
into the social fabric to awaken other
expressions of infinity
so we are dora the infinite explorer
i am that
and my speed at which i
turn inward from the intoxication of
maya towards that
absolute gps callback
that's the game
that is the game
what's your high score
how quickly can you parse
for metaphysical truth in all of the
dirty
noise of distortion
and that was the last six years for me
was just
sifting through all of the noise slowly
one frequency up
one more frequency up okay there's more
signal here keep going
and up and up in signal all the way to
finding the most
refined metaphysical truth about our
true nature
and honing in on that full time until
boom piercing the veilus veil
metaphysical truth yields
to earnest seeking
metaphysical truth yields
to earnest seeking
the more devoted you are to metaphysical
truth
the more likely and the faster
it will yield
so ask yourself what's my high score
what am i distracted by what am i not
disciplining myself with right now
why am i engrossed in the intoxications
of maya
what is this expression of infinity here
what is this one communicating about
signal where is the signal
i'll dedicate myself part time at least
to start
on the signal and i'll see what happens
how much happier how much more peaceful
how much more
awe how much more truth i will have and
be able to catalyze
on
the dream creation design
and this is also what i was saying above
with parmenidus and heraclitus because
ultimately these two about 2500 years
ago
recognized basically the essence of
metaphysics
which is that parmenidus comes up to say
that
all is merely an illusion
very much like the adi shankara theory
of
maya which
only came into play about
a thousand or so years ago in comparison
and when parmenidus says all is merely
an illusion
all change is merely an illusion he's
referencing to the
absolute attributeless agentless
metaphysical zero when heraclitus says
that ponte rey everything flows no man
steps in the same river twice
he's also correct
heraclitus also said that the
nature of reality is like
a bow with the two ends
and the string in between
which is exactly what the tiget do
about a thousand years ago by jiao dunyi
was formed as which is the monism
and the dualistic yin yang within it the
taijitsu
and that's what heraclitus was talking
about regarding the bow
the two poles in flux and like we've
done content on walter russell as well
it's the rhythmic
balanced interchange
that ascension
towards that attractor that we're all
playing as expressions of infinity
symphonically toward this godhead this
auroboros
which is why sir roger penrose has the
cyclic cosmology so even
the most cutting edge science is being
synthesized
with spirituality now and so
in many ways heraclitus is referring to
maya
you will never see the same creation
design again
we've never seen the same creation
design
and we're never going to see the same
creation design there's no beginning
there's no end that's what eternity
infinity mean
and you'll never come to the end because
this is boundless
and so there's so many different
dreamed creations to explore so many
different phenomenologies to explore
so many different civilizational
trajectories to explore so many
different places to call home
that are not even planets orbiting stars
where you don't even have
this style of vehicle that's carbon
based in dna encoded and has four limbs
and two eyes
and so this is the ideas you have to
walt disney use your imagination
and envision all of the dream creation
design
possibility space and recognize yourself
as infinity as source
that is all of that and it is none of
that
it's beyond everything and beyond
nothing
changeless change that's it
metaphysical zero changeless and then
eternal
change also simultaneously
you'll never step in that same river
twice
and again it's the unmanifested
eternally modulating as
all possible experiences you'll never
come to the end of all of the possible
combinations of songs
you can't come to the end of all of the
possibilities of music
you'll never come to the end of that
this is the eternal symphony the eternal
fireworks
this is but one song or one firework
show in eternity and it's just gonna
keep playing songs
keep undergoing more fireworks
even quantum mechanically at the mo at
the level of
no everything is no thing everything is
underlying energy modulating
appearing as form and matter you'll
never come to the end of that underlying
energy
that modulates as the infinite
possibilities
of form and matter
so it's like okay this is double helical
dna
atcg encoded
now imagine completely different biology
you know you use your imagination
will never come to the end of
exploration
and this is pretty important as well
given everything that's happening with
neoadvisor right now
is that anger dissolves upon truth
realization
you haven't actually realized truth
if anger still exists
to become a buddha an awakened one
you can't have
the roots of suffering and misery be
flailing around egoically
as anger and jealousy and frustration
and craving and aversion and greed
because you can't intellectually say
as the ego there's nothing to seek this
is all just a dream
i am already whole i know non-duality
and then for you to
being a contracted energy by being angry
and
all of those other pathological emotions
that your butterfly affecting on your
family your friends
the community in the world non-duality
and anger
can't coexist
otherwise truth has not been realized
non-duality can't just say that all
appearances are equal
in the ultimate all appearances are
equal
in the ultimate this is eternity
infinity appearing
and it's just going to keep appearing
and that's what the non-dual says
and that's great and it's true and yet
simultaneously
it's also true that
very clearly
what is laid out in the simultaneity
with the dualistic
understanding which in the tiget to it's
the monism
and the yin yang at the same time
where you have suffering and you have
well-being and for you
to not even take a glance at how
across thousands of years we've been
teaching people how to eradicate the
roots of suffering and misery and
maximize your well-being and your family
and your friends and community and
society's well-being and prosperity
that is ignorance
that is ignorance because you know
better
tap into that seeking impulses the
truest thing about
you like bentino massaro said nothing is
more true about you than that seeking
impulse
that's the absolute gps callback for you
to go all the way
like charles bukowski said go all the
way
drill all the way to water like dustin
deperno was teaching us
chase two rabbits catch neither that's a
zen cone
and you really really got to dig
all the way to water recognize
all the way the diamond that's already
around your neck
pierce the veilus veil dissolve
the egoic contraction to where it's only
the shared eternal awareness
and then even beyond that to where it's
just that source just that infinitude
but if you haven't dissolved the
contracted egoic
entity you will have eruptions of anger
even if you're saying ah i know
non-duality
and this was from rupert spyra as well
the highest
devotion slash prayer to god slash
infinity
is to knowingly be yourself
and bentino masara was saying this as
well also
be yourself know thyself
the highest devotion slash prayers to
god slash infinity
is to knowingly be yourself
go all the way to that source infinitude
and knowingly be yourself be
that and be that
expressing itself uniquely in the
streamed creation design
be yourself
it's a great way to wrap this has been
the little satori report
so i hope it brought you value hope it
was fun
and i would love to hear your thoughts
in the comments below write me a little
message we'd love to hear from you
i adore hearing from you so much fun
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet
like the video it helps the youtube
algorithm
and
share the video with people that you
feel would
benefit from this and become more
comfortable with sharing their own
satori as well
also right before the macro satori
on december 5th 2020
i did my first heroic dose of magic
mushrooms
so i had five grams of psilocybin
silicin
and i had a really profound and
exceptional experience and theogenically
and so that was also very influential
and very grateful to sky into sunny
and the healing hustlas they grow some
of the best magic mushrooms
here locally in la
and ship
you can find them on instagram and place
an order
just send them a dm and theogens are a
critical part around
the god slash infinity
source realization
and as you
support what we're doing if you'd like
to you can hit the join button
and join us and gain exclusive perks and
then everything that you'll
help fuel is things like what we
discussed where
we will popularize the dissemination
of people's experiences around satori
right with that waddat al-wujud the
unity of all unveiling and finding
everyone has their own unique as an
expression of infinity their own unique
style
of realizing that they are an expression
of infinity
and so we'll be sharing more content
around that
and producing that which is exciting and
i adore you
thank you infinite love thanks so much
and
let's popularize
the macro level ambition
for that enlightened civilization
maximizing human potential and also
to popularize the
coolness around satori and sharing
our satori experiences and that seeking
impulse being the truest thing about you
to pierce the veil is fail and to re
realize yourself as infinity as source
expressing itself
thank you
yay
i love this cute shirt lots of colors on
this one looks like a bunch of paint
you know very childlike
pablo picasso retain
that inner child that youthful awe
creativity bliss
peace all the way through adulthood
maybe we will sing a little
about global enlightenment
we can catalyze whatever
infinity expressing itself
one infinite creator expressing
itself hey one infinite creator
expressing itself hey
retain that child like play it's key
you